[Music]
foreign
we know these people you know the
almighty anime characters who rarely if
ever lose as expected these characters
have often garnered a more polarized
reception specifically in a certain role
on the more serious shows that aren't
obvious parodies nonetheless I'd love to
talk about these characters and we'll be
doing it right now before I get started
I want to let you know I'm going to be
doing this in a more random way given
the nature of the topic this will not be
a power level debate because reasonably
speaking how can you put an Unstoppable
force and an immovable object with
wildly varying powers and scaling we
start with tatsuyashiba
foreign
was in full bloom back when mahoka's
first season aired and having updated
myself with the novels all the way to
the end I'd say that status quo's here
to stay the funny thing about mahoka is
that it tries to put our protagonist as
an underdog early on with their
admission systems classifying him as a
weed and a regular a lesser magician in
layman terms he had little talent and
all oh how those systems failed horribly
underneath the slow casting speed in
which his status as an irregular is
determined lies one of the most genius
magical engineers in the world of mahoka
his skills are analyzing and countering
anything are just impeccable he can even
bring himself and other people back to
life I mean this is a guy who beat a
sniper with his trusty handgun for God's
sake with the same handgun eradicates an
entire terrorist organization in their
Hideout how about vaporizing an entire
Army from the safety of his military
base like what he did in The Season's
first climax yeah that's right all hail
tatsuya
now before we resume our list of
characters who never lose why don't you
try taking the role of one of those
characters the power is yours thanks to
today's sponsor Aura Kingdom become the
protagonist of your story and reach
Unthinkable Heights with this hit MMORPG
Aura Kingdom is an anime RPG that takes
you to the colorful world of azuria as
an Envoy of Gaia players can then choose
to be one of the 17 classes in order to
explore the world clear dungeons with
friends and test their wits against the
Unstoppable monsters that lie in the
world however exploring Dungeons and
defeating bosses isn't everything you
can do with over 2 000 costumes and
similarly plenty of customization
options you can let your creativity run
wild with designing your house or your
character or a kingdom features some of
the best and most well-designed pet
systems that I've known in an MMO you
don't see this kind of longevity out of
a game often and it's a testament to the
game's constant Evolution and creativity
so what are you waiting for come join
the fun it's never too late to hop in
and be a part of the Aura Kingdom and
all you need to do is to follow the link
below a world of Adventure awaits and I
hope to see you soon future envoys
why stop with one dengeki Bunko lead
when you can have two introducing are
not valdi God in the midst of the
jam-packed and blockbust delayed in
summer 2020 season is a Hidden Gem
Misfit of Demon King Academy as people
have pointed out it's the one punch man
of these magic fantasy light novels it's
a show that Revels in its Ridiculousness
and a lot of that has to be in its
portrayal of The League character arnos
we're talking about a Demon Lord so
strong that he got so bored of winning
and just allowed himself to be sealed
only to reawaken thousands of years
later to a vastly different world which
he so easily dominates and brings to his
knees anyway disposition wise arnos kind
of reminds me of datsuya just with more
gloating and a dose of relishing in his
strength as a character he does have his
hidden depths though and is definitely a
Demon Lord you'd want on your side this
is a guy who won't die when he's killed
literally just ask all the foolish
characters who dare become his enemies
in the show it's
like
from light novels we move on to Shonen
manga and one of the coolest teachers
you can have Goro Sensei there's a lot
of things to like about assassination
classroom it's quirky has a unique plot
and has some good plot developments that
made it such a beloved Shonen one thing
that people might notice about Goro
Sensei is just how overpowered he is I
personally like Goro Sensei for a lot of
things besides his strength but just how
strong and undefeatable he is is
certainly a topic for discussion this is
an alien thing that partially destroys
the moon and is set on a collision
course with the destruction of Earth
first day in class and we already see
that those claims weren't things of
Legends he's as overpowered as they come
and all of a sudden the students main
quest seems a lot more daunting than
they all actually expected assassinating
this alien octopus is virtually an
impossible task and that's why I put
Goro Sensei on this list
[Music]
ah who doesn't know my hero Academia I'm
pretty sure that whole lot of you are
familiar with the series already as well
as its themes of friendship acceptance
and a lot more while the students and
most teachers go through their share of
trials and tribulations in this series
one hero stands above them is the
ultimate Beacon of Justice the
infallible all might the number one
ranked hero and the coolest teacher
surrogate father you could possibly get
yeah it's pretty much impossible for all
might to lose in the series even though
he came really close at some point most
notably his ultimate battle against all
for one for me what makes all my such a
great character as far as unbeatable
ones go is how honest his powers are
there's no broken reality warping thing
or talking someone back to life there's
nothing like that he's just someone who
fights with all his heart and passion
short-some depiction of his powers can
be a little bit over the top but we get
nothing close to the ridiculous of say
arnos
foreign
[Music]
27-0 all 27 wins are as a result of a KO
the record that speaks for itself and
takamura has all the reason in the world
to be called The Almighty the nickname
that he had oh so deservingly earned
over his conquest of the multiple boxing
divisions in Hajime no ippo besides the
track record there's no doubt that
darkam order is just a fighter who
overflows with Charisma he's loud Brash
and Incredibly cocky but beneath that
loudness lies an ambitious and
occasionally socially awkward guy who's
had some quite bad luck with the ladies
for me the most admirable trait of his
is his heart and determination has
carried him to that 27-0 record as I
said never underestimate the heart of a
champion and you can see that play out
in full when you watch some of the most
epic Encounters in the series such as
that fierce battle against eagle
picking within JoJo's amazing gallery of
broken characters were actually quite
hard but once I trimmed the list down to
characters who barely lost the choice
became that much easier enter Diono from
the franchise's golden wind Saga now why
would this guy be a character who barely
lost despite more impactful characters
having their fair share of defeats now I
think that it's largely to do with this
extremely versatile and Powerful stand
gold experience for the untrained eye
seems like an underwhelming stand mainly
used to produce plants and small animals
however therein lies its power for it
has the power to govern over life itself
that's already an amazing power to
complement a furious close combat
abilities of gold experience but things
get turned up to 11 when it gets
upgraded into gold experience Requiem
talk about the reality warping powers
that have long lorded anime for where
else can you see an ability that causes
a death Loop yep that's right giono
belongs here and you might want to check
out golden win to see him in action
[Music]
me
the title of world's strongest vampire
is something that often gets handed in
various vampire anime you see people
calling someone's strongest vampire the
strongest vampire there personally I
think the one who lives up to that title
the most is none other than helsing's
Alucard he does not mess around and
instead of giving you a rundown of his
plethora of broken abilities I'll just
ask you to watch Helsing and see his
glory in action Alucard just
systematically breaks down his enemies
with sheer unrestrained violence he's
every 2 000 edgy kids wet dream just
looking at the Aesthetics the badassness
and the personality in all seriousness
though I put I look hard on this list
because as a character he's more than
just the violence or the badass Powers
he has a surprising amount of death put
into his personality and he does have
some endearing traits to make helsink
ultimate such a delight to watch
English
we had thoughtsuya and honors so why not
complete the trifecta of overpowered
light novel leads with their Legion of
admirers who look up to them at every
turn sorry Kirito you should have won
all of your fights anyway I could call
Overlord and irons highlight rule if I
want to with just how much power he
showed in the series yeah it's a given
that he never loses his fight but what
about his one-man Army moments his fight
with charlter which he won despite being
at a disadvantage well there's the time
he effortlessly decimated an entire army
with magic much like what datsuya did
Ice differentiates himself from the rest
of the overpowered light novel heroes in
his morality yeah I mean I'd say he's
not a completely evil bad guy per se
even if he straddles that line very very
precariously but this is a person who
doesn't play nice at all the title
Overlord is just perfect for someone
like eins but it's cool that underneath
that a moral skeleton body you still
find the slightest tinge of humanity
from the time he was an ordinary gamer
foreign
character made the biggest Mark in the
anime Community The Runaway winner would
have to be Gojo not only did his feature
episodes and his last minute says blow
the community up all the time he always
won his battles with style and Flair I'm
not sure whether I like his battle with
jogo or the appearance during the show's
equivalent to a tournament Arc better
but it's not like it matters though is
it both instances were crowning moments
and some of the signature scenes that
people will always remember Jujutsu
Kaizen for and it all came in the hands
of the laid-back reverse Kakashi to boot
curses everywhere have all the right to
be afraid of this all-powerful sorcerer
who's also one of the best mentors that
our upstarts can ever hope to have with
how Jiu Jitsu Kaizen is I don't see
Gojo's undefeated record Being shattered
anytime soon the best thing the villains
can do is hold him back or see in his
powers or something like that it's gonna
take no less than the final boss of the
entire series to possibly give him his
first decisive defeat and I personally
like it that way
of course saithama has to find his way
to this list he's the all-powerful one
punch man after all the ultimate hero
capable of defeating enemies with a
single punch saithama is the whole
antithesis of the whole idea that hard
work hardly Works take that showing in
protagonists with destined one status I
wouldn't say that saitama is my favorite
amongst these listed characters but I
think the one punch man as a Series has
done a great job in pioneering and never
before seen parody of the Shonen genre
I'm sure it's not the only one out there
but it sure is the one that helped anime
explode into the public eye after what
Attack on Titan did a few years prior it
also helps that within the comedic and
parodying nature of one punch Man by
several well-woven stories full of tear
jerkers and awesome moments that make
you go yeah if you haven't done so yet
please watch the first season of one
punch man Feast your eyes on its awesome
animation epic fights and some
surprisingly emotional moments
foreign
the list ends there but I want to know
who your favorite undefeated characters
are let's have a talk in the comments
section and we can probably discuss
about some honorable mentions that I
didn't mention if you enjoyed the video
please like the video by clicking the
thumbs up subscribe and try checking out
my other videos too this channel has a
lot of countdown videos but if you
actually prefer the more video essay
like ones you can check out my other
channel vinichu Kai it mostly has videos
about popular shows like Attack on Titan
or Sword Art online but recently I also
started branching off to more underrated
shows that you might be able to enjoy
such as the latest video on gosic I've
also got memberships and patreon so if
you want to support the channel
financially I'd be really glad don't
forget to check out our sponsors game
Aura Kingdom links in the description a
world of Adventure awaits and I hope to
see you soon future envoys thanks for
watching and I hope you had fun see you
next time
[Music]